let's listen to what he had to say well
i want to be
straight with people it's actually a
difficult decision to make but
in the end we've seen two things really
which have caused concern
one is the positivity rate has nearly
doubled
since the last review in portugal and
the other is that there's a sort of
nepal mutation of the so-called indian
variant which is being detected and we
just don't know
the potential for that to be a
vaccine-defeating
mutation and simply don't want to take
the risk as we come up to the
21st of june and and the review
of the fourth stage of the unlock
the travel industry is obviously
internal today with this news
um are you going to provide more support
for them extended furlough scheme
the grant scheme yes the support for the
travel industry who goodness knows have
suffered throughout this crisis is
ongoing we've got seven
billion pounds worth of support which is
still being paid out right now including
through the
uh furlough scheme look what i want to
do with today's difficult but i hope
decisive
uh action is make sure that we protect
the
future by not restarting problems uh
which
may or may not be there at home uh we'll
be able to get
international travel down the line
opened more quickly
so it's a sort of safety first approach
which i see that gatwick and others
uh have said is an understandable
approach given
where we are in the fourth stage of the
unlock
but will you extend a furlough scheme
for them will you make guarantee that
there will be support there for the
industry given that they are
looking likely to be in for a difficult
summer yes i mean look i think
uh the the travel industry the aviation
sector suffered enormously that's why we
provided seven billion pounds of support
and that that supports ongoing
including at the moment the furlough
scheme as well so
uh we've just done more for the ground
handlers
and for the airports themselves by way
of sort of a rates rebate effectively
and we'll always look to support them
the best thing we can do is get back to
being able to travel internationally
and we are working for example with g7
partners uh the oecd
and other international uh bodies to get
this going again
but the first thing to do is to protect
the unlock
domestically and not put that at danger
which potentially a vaccine defeating
mutation
could do so it's a safety first measure
when i was at gatwicker earlier today
there were plenty of people who were
traveling out to ambulance countries now
that there are
essentially no holiday destinations or
very few holiday destinations on the
green list
do you not think that people are going
to just continue to travel to ambulance
countries and what are you doing
to try and limit people doing that well
the vast majority of people
are not saying that they're going to
travel at the moment and of course
keeping it open as to whether they
travel this summer depends depending on
what happens
so that's the majority of people um uh
we've said with the amber and the red
list certainly
red shouldn't be traveling there at all
that is really for people british
citizens
effectively to return from those
countries with amber lis
they're not there for holidays they're
there for emergency situations perhaps a
family member you need to go
and visit and if you do go there you end
up having to come back and a very very
strictly enforced quarantine
exists which includes having to pay for
numerous tests
uh it includes uh potentially people
coming around to your your home to check
your
you're there and i don't think that's
necessarily the kind of
relaxation people want many people can't
take that kind of time off
so a bit of patience here i appreciate
this is a difficult decision
i understand that you know we are all
desperate to see the world return to
normal that can only happen through the
domestic unlock
first we all look towards the 21st of
june to see
uh what can be done and the data and we
simply don't want to put that at risk
through these figures uh as we said as
we say as you've seen in portugal
both the uh doubling of the positivity
rate that we've seen and also
this mutation uh the so-called nepal
mutation on the so-called indian variant
which could then
cause us problems down the line so
safety first to get our unlock done
at home